hey welcome back everybody today we're
going to do some disking with our dirt
dog disc on the kubota m4 tractor now
dirt dog does offer discs to fit
tractors big and small so we have them
as small as four foot wide if you're
looking for something for a subcompact
tractor you know the five six seven foot
range everywhere in between two you're
going to see these are two rows on this
disc right here and they are going to be
able to be offset so you can have them
that are pretty much straight in line
just for the light tilling or you can
make them really aggressive on steep
angles to really get an aggressive turn
of your soil and everywhere in between
now disking is typically going to be a
kind of a final run or a final pass that
you can do prior to planting your seed
the very popular alternative would be
using a rototiller which i absolutely
love now this is the first run with a
dirt dog disc caro i've used these in
the past they do work well i don't think
they're going to give you the same
finished results as a rototiller wood
not the most consistent seed bed but
we're going to try it in a couple of
spots today a few weeks back we did a
long stretch with a big old sub soiler
and ripped down over 20 inches close to
two foot down we're going to be putting
in a screening cover right here to kind
of give us a little bit of distinction
as hunting season comes around in the
fall and so oftentimes you are going to
do some sort of a deep tillage
application it could be with a plow it
could be with a sub soiler and you would
come through afterwards with a disc or a
rototiller for your final preparation
i'm going to show you a couple different
areas today one of them will be where we
did previously do that deep tillage
another area is going to be where we
haven't done any kind of soil
disturbance at all so you'll see this
farm ground here has not been tilled it
has not been worked in well over a
decade so it's not great soil right it's
got a lot of clay in it a lot of sand a
lot of small stones
the top soil is just so so at best so
you're going to have a chance to see how
the disc caro does on something that's
been previously worked up as well as
we're going to call it virgin ground and
see if it gives you the desired results
now these discards will work with any
category one uh three-point hitch
they're also going to be quick hitch
compatible the bigger guys will work
with category two three points as well
dirt dog attachments are made down in
georgia so they're made in the usa
a few other points worth noting you are
going to have sealed ball bearings in
all of the axles a two inch square tube
frame all around your gangs are going to
be held on by a three by i think it's
one and a half inch square tube or
rectangular tube
in the black that you can see here and
you're gonna see we have an optional
scraper kit added on that's what these
little uh u brackets are that are
clamped down with these black rods that
are hanging along that's a scraper kit
so uh the mud and debris will kind of
clean off a little bit easier so we're
going to go ahead and adjust these to a
bit more of an aggressive angle then
we're going to get to work but don't
forget
goodworxtractors.com we sell and ship
tractor attachments all over the country
not just discs but your rototillers your
brush hogs your flail mowers pallet
forks snow pushers you name it the list
goes on so check it out
goodworxtractors.com
[Music]
so
foreign
do
[Music]
so
um
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
me
[Music]
as always we're sponsored by borah wheel
spacers they are made in america have a
lifetime warranty if your tractor feels
tippy side to side especially if you
have a cab on it then adding a set of
wheel spacers can make a big difference
get more information on them at the link
down below
[Music]
so
alrighty folks there you have it you
have a look right where we're standing
this is where we had done that deep
tillage and on the far side near the
road frontage is where we tilled that
virgin ground up so not really much of a
difference in results i don't think so i
think it'd be okay either way now that
is four passes we went down and back
twice on each one of these strips so
imagine the amount of time that it would
take you and it's really easy right
you're just dropping it down and going
but it's going to take you a while to do
but i do have a hydraulic top link on
here which is nice to make those
adjustments from the operator seat
you know it's a little bit of playing
around with the speed with the angle of
that top length to get the right
you know i mean the optimal i guess
conditions for the disc and i did adjust
this i went with the most aggressive
position the first down and back in both
areas and then i adjusted it made it a
little bit less aggressive there's four
different settings or four different
angles so i made it one less aggressive
setting on there and did another pass on
it
you know i don't think if i go any less
aggressive it's going to make it any
better you know i could go over it again
and again and i think it would improve
the results and if i had a larger field
you know like if i did this whole field
right now um i could come at it from
different angles kind of crisscross it
as well and that would certainly break
up these clumps and these clods a little
bit better and we're gonna get to doing
areas like that later this spring this
is just for a screening cover that we're
trying to get in right now
but what you see on here these are going
to be notched discs that are on here
they have smooth this as well the
notched ones are going to be better for
breaking up kind of the sod and the and
the heavy matter and debris that's in
here say you have a cornfield with some
corn stubble afterwards and you're
knocking that all down so really good
for that these scrapers came into play
really nicely
the last time i used a disc several
years ago it's been a while
there's just huge clumps of dirt and
everything that we're getting on there
so the same problem that has plagued me
on discs for smaller tractors like what
you see here is really kind of that
weight ratio you know you want a lot of
weight kind of pushing down into the
ground to help your your disc do its
thing and there were times if i was
going too fast that it felt like it
wanted to ride up on top of the ground
instead of down in it and going through
it
some of that was top link adjustments
that i was making some of that was speed
too but
the benefit of one of these discs is
that you can go through different
terrain you know you saw a lot of sticks
and roots and things like that that a
tiller may otherwise struggle with and a
tiller is going to be slower but
one pass is going to yield the results
that i think personally are better than
four passes with a disc and so the
kubota here has a little speedometer on
there tells you how fast you're going
and i was bouncing between
second and third gear and low range and
i was going from 2.1 to
2.56 miles per hour so going faster than
tiller of course
but you can see these finish results
which overall aren't terrible but
they're nowhere near what a tiller can
do and there's certain areas out here
that are well this is really good right
here actually but there's certain areas
up top and a couple of different spots
where it looks like there's just big old
chunks of sod still and of course that
crisscross hatch would fix that but just
an observation anyway we've got a lot of
tilling videos coming up whether it's
with a disc or a tiller or a plow
planting all sorts of stuff we're going
to put some pollinator
seed out here as well have some
wildflowers growing the field across or
behind this
fence row here we're going to turn into
a lot of different food plots where in
northwoods whitetails food plot seed
dealer as well so we're just getting set
up with them so look for more
information from them on our website and
again if you're looking for a tractor
attachment something for the three-point
hitch for the front end loader we're
happy to help we sell and ship all over
the country check out
goodworkstractors.com if you want to see
those future videos make sure you hit
that subscribe button get to know what
these tractors are all about if you have
your own projects planned for the future
maybe you'll learn some things not to do
by watching us either way i want to
thank you for taking time out of your
day to stop by and until next time stay
safe we'll see you soon all right so
chris and i were talking about it we're
gonna do one final pass
make it a little bit less aggressive
even yet
see what it ends up looking like we'll
see you later
[Music]
good
so
[Music]
you